we can't rate from the helicopter right
right to here we're late yet again here
we are at the world drone cream in Dubai
2016
yeah
okay so scoops with the boys scoop
through the run
I like
okay
- bye
Oh
having a great time 10 attend wooden
door again so we've been up all night
7:00 a.m. la time so we're super tired
yep for like this race is so cool can
you go
it's jobs two dividers good for the by
so tired I didn't sleep at all and
Carmichael got up super early again got
comin a mile tall
so carmichael the helicopter wasn't
enough yesterday we're about to go up
into the tallest building in the world
so I want to really make this disclaimer
very crystal clear I feel really bad
Michael that's a hot boy but that's
still higher than everything here Tom
Cruise you get to go up onto the top of
the spire I've been misled my entire
life I thought I was Tom Cruise switch
it off just the security came over and
worse people demanded he deleted every
single bit of footage I had microphone
has been taken away so you might notice
bit of a difference in the audio quality
you're the coolest
oh wow those were mattock brownie before
whoa you'll probably never seen it but
Tom Cruise good for you come here come
on move closer to the glass come on
move closer save me Tom Cruise is
impressive I'm like really hot yeah I'll
give you $50 if you get close to the
glass he just offered you 50 US dollars
to touch the glass no just you need to
hog the glass for a good 30 seconds
I'm gonna do what he's offering you to
do yes yeah and look and look down a
peer pressure doing four think of the
people hug the glass and look down
spread your legs a bit more magic
starfish you want look how far you can
fall
you're not you're not kidding okay yeah
you mean adopted well honey I thought
you were joking when you said I have no
okay oh yeah I do yeah
no Brian he deserves a right now giving
in to didn't know he did see you did it
and that is incredible we made
Carmichael's the conquer his fear by
going on the glass and looking down he
was frozen solid in here can you go get
off the window we actually have to do in
this dick see this isn't bad because
there's things I can fall and hit on the
way down
yeah you're contained but when your
entire field of view is just nothing but
a drop this is [ __ ] impressive and
awesome even though I'm terrified
that's the left do you buy jelly
shooting a video aren't you tired